hello and welcome to Columbia or to this
building I think it's actually I work in
a law school library and Kent McKeever I
run the library and this is to be honest
the first time I've been in this
building it could be very isolated
different places on campus this is the
last of the sessions this year on
scholarly communication and we have
three people speaking on the issues of
copyright and scholarship and how the
business works now and perhaps will work
in the near future I'm agog about this
because I come from the law library
world which has the law publishing and
academic policy in law is its own weird
little economic system that bears
virtually no relationship to anybody
else's so this is all new to me our
guests our guests our speakers today
will be first of all Kenny Cruz many of
you have probably already met him he's
the director of the copyright advisory
office here at Columbia for more than 20
years as research has focused on
copyright issues particularly as they
related to the needs of scholarship and
the university coming to Columbia he was
before coming to Columbia excusing he
was a professor of law and of Library
and Information science at Indiana
University dr. Cruz is the author of
several books and articles on copyright
law teaches copyright law at the
Columbia Law School and an advanced
degree program in Munich our second
speaker is Michael Carroll a founding
member of the board of directors of
Creative Commons a global nonprofit
organization dedicated to providing
legal and technical tools to facilitate
information sharing by authors educators
scientists and all other creative
individuals fest Carroll is also an
active advocate for open access on the
Internet and to the scientific and
scholarly literature professor Carroll
was himself a spike on the blogosphere
earlier this week when it was announced
that he was accepting a full-time
position at American University
Washington College of Law which is where
this one graduated from
Lord only knows how well their alumni
mafia work professor Carroll's research
and teaching specialties are
intellectual property law and cyber law
until this year he was a member of the
Faculty of Villanova and before that he
practiced at Wilmer Cutler and served as
a law clerk to judge Judith Robert
Rogers of the Court of Appeals the DC
Circuit and Joyce hens Greene of the
district court of the District Columbia
the third speaker will be Heather Joseph
who's been executive director of the
scholarly publishing and academic
resources Coalition commonly known as
SPARC since 2005 and it supports
expanding access to the results of
scholarly research through enabling open
access publishing and archiving and
advocating for open access policies MS
Joseph is also a spokesperson for the
Alliance for taxpayer access coalition
spent a leading voice on un open US open
access legislation particularly for
materials that we as citizens have
already paid for through our taxpayer
based grants she has spent 15 years in
the scientific journal industry both in
commercial and not-for-profit
organizations and serves on the board of
directors of numerous not-for-profit
organizations she is a frequent speaker
and writer on scholarly communication
and on open access in particular they
will speak in that order Kenny will
start then professor Carroll and miss
Joseph when we get to the question and
answer period after the speaks the talks
we do have someone with a boom mic who
will come around and stick the mic in
your face when you ask a question
because this will also be going out as a
podcast and we want to get everybody's
questions and the answers out as clearly
as possible so Kenny you want to take
off sir
thank you
Thank You Kent and let me find bring
this alive and projector on and there we
are there we are wonderful thank you
thank you all very much I know it's a
lovely spring day outside isn't it
wherever you might be so it's good to
see you here and there are too many
people to thank but be sure to look
around the room and thank the people who
made this event possible
so getting down to business getting down
to business our question is who really
owns your scholarly work and the first
question that we really should be asking
is who cares and there are many answers
to the question of who cares if you're
the one who is it's really your
scholarly work you're the one who's
producing this work the first answer is
you care and you care for a variety of
reasons because how your work is owned
and controlled under whatever mechanism
is going to make all the difference
about the advancement of your work and
the future of your own scholarship and
we'll be showing how some of this comes
through it a little bit later in the
presentation
publishers care because the question of
ownership or control goes straight to
the economic model of publishing
whatever that economic model might be
traditional or innovative it also goes
to the question of the growth and
survival of publishers especially
publishers in a traditional sense who
are now facing some formidable
challenges with respect to the ability
to keep the system of publishing as we
know it keep it afloat libraries care
libraries care because they're facing
questions of escalating cost they're
facing conflicts with the mission of
information access and readers users
researchers they care because they too
are finding that exactly at the time
where there's increased access to
information we're encountering new
sometimes burdensome barriers to the
retrieval and use of that information
this is a long list to be able to
address but it's a list that I think we
can begin to formulate by going back and
rethinking that question of who owns
your scholarly work and so why now is
really the next important question why
in the world are we bothering with this
question now when we know that our
environment of scholarship has been in
existence for well over a century as in
a formula that's very similar to what we
know it today and indeed we can clock it
back a few centuries so why now it's
because we're seeing some change in this
ecology of information creation and
information use we're seeing new
technologies that are creating new
opportunities for dissemination of works
for control of works and confusion about
the use and opportunities and abilities
to use scholarly works we're seeing new
and diverse formats and new media come
into existence as the vehicle of
communication of scholarship this
digital diversity of all different types
and what we might call multi-directional
scholarly communication blogs wiki's
other forms of communication where it
isn't just one direction
it isn't just from me to my audience but
it's it's a group it's a consortium it's
a pooling of ideas and thinking and
creativity to formulate what we know
today as scholarly communication why now
- we also have new players or we could
say changing players coming to the table
we have familiar players taking on new
roles we have libraries functioning more
and more as publishers we have readers
becoming authors we have the public
as an investor in the creation of
research in the first place the public
as a responsive author the public as a
reviewer we've talked a lot or at least
I have in the last couple of minutes
about about the the the nature of the
creation and publication of scholarship
but a critical element that we may not
say a whole lot about today is peer
review and peer review is shifting as
well and the public is being is stepping
in in many cases as the reviewer as the
critique as providing that feedback in
this multi-directional
realm of scholarly communication and
another new player of course is Google
and more Google and Google doing more
things Google as publisher Google as
creator Google as connector Google as
disseminator and if it isn't Google it's
somebody else and so we're seeing these
new players and changing players and
then we're also seeing changing law back
to the theme of copyright which we'll
get to in just a moment we're seeing
that there's change in copyright law and
a lot of that change especially through
the last 10 or so years has been in the
direction of ramping up copyright
protection stronger protection for a
longer period of years more different
types of protection and so the question
of who owns and who then possesses the
copyright becomes an even more powerful
more influential more controlling kind
of conclusion and so I'll be talking a
lot in the next few minutes about the
importance of contracts but let's put
those contracts into the context of the
legal framework of copyright here are
just a few things that you need to know
about copyright to make sense of the
rest of the subject first copyright law
protects nearly everything well what do
I mean by that
it protects nearly everything that you
can see read watch or hear it protects
works that have these two qualities they
are original works of authorship
that are fixed in a tangible medium of
expression I wrote it on paper it's my
original authorship now fixed on paper
or it's something that's stored to the
hard driver on a web server are captured
in the camera all of these are different
ways of taking original content and
fixing it and what do we get when we
pass those tests we get instant
automatic copyright protection no
requirement to do anything no
requirement to put formalities a see in
a circle no requirement to know that you
have copyright in fact if you don't even
want the copyright you get it anyway so
it's instant automatic copyright that's
imposed on all of those diverse works
and it's a protection that lasts for a
long long long period of years the basic
term the law is more complicated than
this but our basic term of copyright is
life of the author Plus 70 more years so
pause again and think about that
question of ownership of the copyright
ownership of the scholarship we're
talking about rights legal rights
broadening legal rights that somebody
now will possess for many many many
decades to come so there's our
foundation now let's go to the issue of
ownership in particular and examine it
in this context who owns the copyright
if we asked that question
we kind of get an answer and we're gonna
get a reasonably clear answer in most
cases but let's struggle a little bit we
have our basic rule that if we default
to the law who owns the copyright in
that journal article and that website
and that recording on the camera it's
the author
it's whoever did the original work is
the copyright owner there's our starting
point and if you have multiple parties
multiple contributors a discussion among
all of us
then we start to have joint copyright
ownership and we can have multiple
authors sharing in the copyright I hope
you're starting to see the possibilities
of confusion we'll come back to that too
now sometimes I call the the second half
of the slide appear exceptions to that
rule that's not really quite right let's
think about them as alternatives so
basic rule I'm the one who wrote the
paragraphs I'm the one who owns the
copyright well here's some alternatives
to how that could come out first is the
concept of work made for hire if I
created that work particularly in the
context of being an employee acting
within the scope of my employment my
duties at the University for example
then that could qualify as a work made
for hire in which case my employer owns
the copyright to that particular work so
I'm the one who actually wrote it but
now somebody else owns it next on the
list is transfers very important for our
topic today that week that we might
conclude I own the copyright or you own
the copyright but we might not want that
result for whatever reason the law
allows us to shift that copyright and
move it to somebody else but that we
need to take care of through an
agreement and then very important on the
list is divisibility the notion that the
copyright is not one cohesive Hall it
could be treated in that manner but it
doesn't have to be and so the law gives
us an opportunity to be able to take the
thing called the copyright and unbundle
it to break it up into its pieces and
maybe I only want some pieces and you
want other pieces and somebody else
wants yet another set of pieces we can
do that we can do that but now step back
from the slide a little bit let's let's
emphasize a few larger points we've got
some defaults in the law the way the law
will say it's mine or it's yours
but in that deep
fault all that the law will do is grant
all rights to that one party so first if
we want a different result not you
owning it but me owning it then we need
to make sure that we attend to that
through a proper transfer or if we want
a sharing of the copyright and
unbundling we have to attend to that in
a proper writing in a proper instrument
and again in both cases this is where
the contract comes in let's talk about
it the benefits of having a publication
agreement it can provide for
fundamentally on our topic for today a
clarification of rights and a sharing of
rights it can do those two things in a
way that the law cannot adequately
accomplish defaulting to the law is
likely to cause more confusion and more
questions so in almost all cases an
agreement is going to be an improvement
because the agreement can get us away
from thinking about that dinosaur the
monolith of the copyright and breaking
it up and sharing it the contract can
help us get away from the confusion is
it mine or is it yours work-for-hire is
it mine or is it yours as my employer
and it can get us away from that and
resolve the confusion that comes from
those questions so an agreement
immediately on this point has some
critical importance so what should a
good publication agreement have here are
a few elements of a good agreement it
should have and in a some kind of
confirmation if it's my agreement with
the publisher I wrote the article the
book whatever it is I might have written
that it identifies that in fact I am the
author that it says so and I'm willing
to write that down and I'm willing to
sign it that might sound so basic but
it's really important and it can be the
opportunity for me to say well wait a
minute I got this picture from another
source I got these pieces from yet
another source it's a chance to
exactly what's what in this work it's a
chance through the agreement to confirm
the copyright status who is going to be
the copyright owner is it going to be me
it's going to be you is it going to be
yet somebody else this is our chance
because through that agreement we can
effect a transfer to clarify where we
want that copyright to end up it's also
our chance to maybe make a statement
about the public domain then maybe you
don't want copyright for this work or
maybe one thing we haven't talked about
is it's not eligible for copyright there
aren't many things out there that fit
this category but one big one is works
of the US government if I happen to be
an officer of the US government in
connection with my writing this work
then there's no protection for that work
at all and the agreement is a chance to
clarify that as well it's also a chance
to if you want if you can reach
agreement with your publisher to say
something about Creative Commons or
other alternative licensing and we're
gonna hear more about Creative Commons
later today but if essentially Creative
Commons is a way of saying that
copyrights mine but I hereby share
rights of use with the public and it's a
chance to let go of some of those rights
that you have under copyright law and
for much of our world of scholarship
that's a good thing the critical
elements of a good publication agreement
will be a license to the publisher now
conventionally you'll often see a
transfer of the copyright to the
publisher I think our our move and what
we're seeing more and more around the
world is a tendency not toward a
transfer of the copyright you the author
hang on to that but rather a license to
the publisher and then that raises the
question so what does the publisher need
I guess at a minimum some rights of reap
reducing the work distributing the work
if it's a like digital delivery
displaying it transmitting it out via
via the internet and so publishers do
need some pieces of the copyright but
they don't need everything they don't
need everything
and as a result here through the
agreement is our chance to create a
sharing model and this is now a sharing
between author and publisher so now we
beginning to split up the copyright and
move it around and take the opportunity
in a good publishing agreement to
specify some rights that are retained by
the author and among those that we that
are of great interest today are the
right to be able to deposit a copy of
this work in a repository such as we
have here at Columbia the right to be
able to meet your obligations under the
open access policy from regarding
funding from NIH and we're going to hear
more about that as well and then the
right to be able to use even your own
work in connection with your own
teaching your own research your own
future endeavours this is really
important and again giving away the
copyright under the traditional model
undercuts even the author's ability to
do good things with scholarly works so
back to our original question multiple
choice answer who owns the scholarship
well here are some possibilities which
one is true and we're going to get
different different responses in
different situations the legal answer if
we resort to the law who owns the
copyright who owns the scholarship well
I guess you do as the author oh but
maybe not maybe it's worked for hire
maybe it's something else now we've got
confusion also what do you mean owned is
it all mine is that all yours is there
any kind of sharing no it's really an
all-or-nothing
position under the law there's also a
university policy kind of approach to
this where we could say that in fact
there's sometimes a that usually a
university policy as we have here at
Columbia preserves to the faculty author
the the the rights to traditional works
of authorship and scholarship and that's
conventional not only here but at most
universities around the country but then
again there are always exceptions as
there are in the policy here and
elsewhere so we have some little bit of
uncertainty there until we resolve it
and so options see the better answer the
contract the contract is a chance to
resolve those uncertainties and come to
the answer that actually serves us
better and then option D what's my final
answer it's keep a copy whichever one of
the preceding answers I picked when you
have an agreement no matter what it is I
say that I'll say this at every
presentation I'll say it over and over
again any kind of agreement that you
have with any publisher for the use of
your material keep a copy absolutely
positively keep a copy remember how long
copyrights last yeah that long a long
time life of the author Plus 70 years
the agreement is going to clarify the
rights and that work for as long as the
copyright lasts for the life of the
copyright for the life of the author
Plus 70 more years keep a copy we need
to see it we need to see that agreement
for a lot of decades to come and so
thank you very much thanks to all of you
and I look forward to the next
presentation and the questions and
answers thank you
thank you very much it's a it's a real
pleasure to be here and want to thank
the organizers of this event and the
scholarly communication program has
really put on a really nice series of
events and I'm happy to be part of the
closing event although I hope that this
is not the closing of the conversation
about scholarly communication just for
this academic year okay so here's what I
want to talk about we will talk a little
bit about authors and the owners their
individual ownerships of copyright but I
want to put that conversation in context
of the larger information environment in
which those copyrights matter and I want
us to think then about the information
environment we currently live in and
think about whether with the capacities
of digital technologies we might not
fashioned for ourselves collectively a
more productive
information environment for scholarly
communication so a quick question and we
have a young audience so this one may
fall on deaf ears but how many people in
the audience routinely recycled their
newspapers and their plastics and cans
twenty-five years ago right a couple of
hands right why well part of it it was
hard right at the time there wasn't
curbside pickup you had to bundle your
trash on Saturday morning put it in the
car burn some fossil fuels to go recycle
your garbage how many people today
routinely recycled paper plastic in the
life okay almost everybody big change in
behavior how did that change in behavior
come about well it started with those
intrepid individuals trekking to the
recycling center on Saturday mornings
because they had a vision of what the
physical environment ought to look like
they had a vision about their role in
this physical environment as consumers
and people who then had waste that they
had to get rid of right so that was a
vision that informed their behavior on
Saturday mornings
eventually that Saturday morning crowd
said there's got to be a better way I
don't want to have to do this
and we moved from individual leaders to
more institutional solutions finally
governments get in involved when you hit
critical mass and the institutions take
responsibility from making this part of
our environment and our part of our
activities so I want to suggest that
we're in the same process with respect
to our information resources and we're
still at this early stage where it's the
intrepid individuals who have a vision
of what the environment environment
needs to look like and are taking
actions as authors as owners of
copyright where copyright becomes an
essential part of the existing
environment that we have and and I want
to make sure that the folks in the
audience and anyone watching on the
webcast are conscious of the current
environment that that we're in so there
have already been some noticeable
changes the move from print to
electronic resources think about it from
the author's perspective if you're
writing for a journal how likely would
you be to publish in the journal that
printed eight I'm sorry published in
print only format wouldn't happen you a
print only print only distribution no
interest in electronic access yeah I
mean there your readership in that world
is going to drop off significantly and
as we hear from Heather a little bit
later there are economic reasons for
that as libraries cannot possibly keep
up with the costs of maintaining print
subscriptions and as publishers are
creating pricing models that are pushing
you into a digital environment but
understand the digital environment that
we've got now you know you know wealthy
university like Columbia University you
live inside a very pleasant well walled
garden right you have the computer there
you want to do research you pull up you
click on a link to a journal article and
voila it comes up what you probably
don't realize is that you passed through
a toll gate that the publisher has on
their on their database where they check
the IP address and say oh that's a
request coming from a computer at
Columbia University I will serve up that
copy right there folks outside the
walled garden who
they click on the link they get the door
slammed in their face okay
because they're outside the wall and
they can't afford to pay it to get in
that's the current information
environment we're living in and I'm
gonna ask challenge you to make an
argument for why that's a sustainable
desirable environment and I want to
argue to you that in fact there's a much
better digital environment that we can
have for scholarly communication that's
economically sustainable that's
environmentally sustainable and will
improve the the overall enlightenment
project of scholarship in the
transmission of knowledge all right and
this is a good news story we've all been
terrorized by the climate change stories
and they are terrifying right but I
don't have to be Al Gore I don't have to
show you ice shelfs falling off I don't
have to show you about the threat I'm
here to present you with an opportunity
all right this is a world of opportunity
to create a better more exciting
information environment right and the
reason I'm here to talk to the authors
in the audience is because you're in
charge right under the roles of
copyright that Kenny just explained
copyright is automatic this has been a
feature of copyright law since 1710
where the author gets the rights right
so understand you're sitting at your
computer writing that first draft you
don't know it but federal law is over
there hovering above you in the minute
you save federal law showers down upon
you a set of exclusive rights you are
now a copyright owner congratulations
all right and so the question is what
are you going to do with that copyright
and the standard story for copyright
doesn't fit the scholarly authors or at
least the scholarly journal author
because the standard story is that the
reason we get the law gives these
exclusive rights is to give an incentive
for the author to write this because
they need to get paid for their activity
and they will then transfer the rights
to a publisher who will share the
revenues the publisher makes with the
author that will stimulate the
creativity that's what Stephen that's
Stephen King's model right that's a one
version of copyright how many folks in
the audience have received a royalty
cheque for their journal articles
no that's not the this is not so the
one-size-fits-all copyright story
doesn't fit here the reason that we can
treat copyright differently in this
space is because the motivations the
incentives the economics are different
right researchers write for these
reasons it's about impact it's about
dissemination so in fact the walled
garden is not in the researchers
interest because it's going to be
slamming the door in the face of
potential readers which is not in the
author's interest okay so but we
currently have a reason for the walled
garden the standard routine is author
submits manuscript gets a letter of
acceptance and then assigns a copyright
agreement or now some publishers have
you click a little I agree button as you
submit and the copyright deal is done is
it a fair deal I don't think so right so
here's one of the worst a scholarly
society the American Chemical Society
the terms of the deal are give us your
copyright we'll give you 50 physical
copies do you want to distribute more at
a conference we do have a license fee
for that we will sell you back your own
article all right and we will sell it to
your institution and it ain't cheap
right okay why and and this agreement
gets signed hundreds of times a month
probably thousands of times a month why
because it's part of the routine just as
it was once part of the routine to take
that can of coke and just throw it in
the trash right it's now part of the
routine that you just sign an agreement
and there's a reason for that be prior
to the digital environment there weren't
a lot of alternatives that was the game
in town it was the only game in town it
was the only form of communicating with
readers so you just did it it was part
of the routine okay but we now have
choice we and and when you have choice
ethical considerations practical
considerations change so one argument I
have which is not appealing to many
authors is I think it's unethical to not
read this and to just sign it okay
because you have a choice to renegotiate
the terms of these as Kenny was
suggesting this does not have to be the
final terms of the deal and they should
not be the terms of the deal right so
here's an example and and I want to make
sure sometimes the open access
conversation gets treated as if it's a
science technical and medical publishing
problem so it's not it's across all
disciplines and so here's JSTOR's become
a repository for back issues of all
kinds of journals including number of
humanities journals you want to see that
walled garden right so I want this
article it's in JSTOR boom ten bucks for
one article I JSTOR has to throw shut
the door in your face as well because
that's their business model okay I we
can watch TV for a little while but
eventually I'm too much of an egotist I
need your attention what can we do to
change and why should we change I mean
this is just this is this new
environment where there are new
opportunities and we've got if I can get
I mean but I guess that's all we can do
right I mean the publishers are there
they're in control we got to give them
control because they're the only game in
town there's no other way to communicate
your research to readers anymore but
other than publishing it in that print
Journal and making sure it gets onto a
library shelf oh there is an alternative
isn't there right there is another way
to disseminate research the Internet is
there to where as long as there's
somebody with an internet access then
why aren't we giving the person with
Internet access access to material that
was written by an author who doesn't
need to get paid to have written it
right now there are costs involved in
the publication process and no one who's
advocating for open access on the
internet denies that right so a couple
of points I want to be clear I'm now
going to start using the word open
access as the desirable endpoint in the
environment what I mean by desirable I'm
sorry what what I mean by open access is
the material is available for free on
the internet
okay that's the open access point
nothing has changed with the publication
process it has still been peer-reviewed
it has still gone through an editorial
gate those tollgate those gates are
important right so I'm not suggesting we
change those gates it's about changing
the terms of access not the terms terms
of publication another important point
open access is sometimes associated with
one particular business model that
achieves the end of free access on the
internet that is not the sum total of
open access open access means there's a
file on the internet that anyone with an
internet access can get to period right
we can now talk about the the money side
how we're going to get that up there how
that's going to be environmentally and
economically sustainable but that's what
open access means right and there are
essentially two different ways to do
that one is to maintain the current
subscription model keep the folks inside
the walled garden give them their
privileged access they get instant
access to the literature right and then
with some minor delay eventually the
material goes up on the open web so
folks outside the wall eventually get
access maybe three months later maybe
six months later but ultimately the
entire scholarly record belongs up on
the open web okay that's that I think
should be a non-negotiable point that
all universities need to grab on to in
the digital environment the scholarly
record belongs in the open web okay and
we can sustain this and we know we can
sustain it because libraries inside the
the privileged walled gardens still need
to be on the cutting edge still need to
give their researchers instant access
they can't afford not to pay those
subscription fees right so the system
remains this will be sustained by those
subscriptions but open access will
remain the default for the long term
okay and this is good for researchers
because you now can reach with open
access five audiences that you don't
currently read
the first and often overlooked is the
serendipitous reader this is somebody
who's inside a privileged institution
with institutional access but who might
not be searching for your article in
that mode instead they're out doing a
regular old Google search they hit a
blog that links you to another link and
suddenly you're linked to an article I I
wish I had the details I should have
written it down there was an NPR story a
medical doctor is working on a rare
disease he discovers that or has an idea
that he needed he needs a drug that she
sort of turns a particular chemical
switch and then he thinks to himself
well maybe some existing pharmaceutical
product already has that property and as
he's telling the the reporter of the
story he says so I went and did a google
search I went and did a Google search to
find the chemical properties of of an
existing pharmaceutical product
researchers use Google too if you're up
on the open web you will be found by the
serendipitous researcher who's just
doing a google search not the person
who's inside the IP wall doing a search
from on campus so that's an important
audience that don't you shouldn't
overlook right there are plenty of
resources researchers in your discipline
who are who can't afford to be inside a
walled garden and as we're gonna hear it
in a minute the price of staying inside
that keeps increasing and that's not
because the costs are increasing but
because we've seen consolidation in the
publishing industry an increasing number
of for-profit publishers who've seen
that this is a fun and good game to be
in while the rest of the publicly held
companies had a great year in 2008 right
but Reed Elsevier wiley-blackwell were
happy to report nice little profits at
the end of the year well the rest of the
market was down 25 30 percent there's a
reason for that but they've got to keep
these under-resourced readers outside to
keep the prices up okay they're
increasingly research has become
interdisciplinary
some of your readers are going to be in
a marginal discipline but can make use
of the knowledge in your discipline and
and vice versa so if I'm in an
institution that only specializes in
some disciplines I'm not going to have
access to a little the literature in
those marginal disciplines increasingly
resources I mean are you confident that
you know what the cutting edge research
is going on in China right now in your
discipline in India and Brazil right
probably not again if we have all this
stuff on the open web we're going to be
able to find out more what's going on in
the rest of the world to me probably the
most important class of readers is the
machine readers right this is the most
frustrating thing and here I will talk
about the science literature science
science information is in a web 1.0
world you cannot follow the links right
you're reading a science article you get
their reference where's the link to the
data set where's the link to all the
other articles in the bibliography why
can't I find those links and follow them
and it doesn't matter that it's not just
that I want to follow them I want to
have a machine that can follow them and
can analyze those links why does Google
work Google works because it analyzes
all the links on the open web it treats
a link as a citation it uses those for
its ranking of relevant results that's
how Google works you can you you can
analyze the links to buy shoes to buy a
computer but you can't do that to find
the article that might have been the
little critical missing piece in your
research and it's because of a
technological impediment that we've tied
ourselves to in this constrained digital
environment in an open digital
environment we can develop digital tools
that will machine read the the the the
text it will text mine analyze the links
and help us deal with the information
overload help us find the needle in the
haystack and
we can't even get that research started
because we don't have the open code base
to get to start that analysis on so
here's some statistics open access these
are you know when you get access to
those additional readers they do read
and then they cite I'm gonna blow
through these because I'm running out of
time but there is this other so that and
here's why I'm nervous about doing this
because opponents of open access say I'm
I'm not going to talk about the
principle of the scholarly record being
available online I'm going to instead
turn this into a conversation about
business models and talk about how it's
impossible to have a business model in
which instead of having the reader side
the demand side pay for access you have
the supply side the author or the
author's institution paying but there
are journals that have switched to this
model to give everybody immediate online
access and that's the that is the key
benefit of this switch so it is an
important switch I don't want to
diminish the importance of that
principle I just don't want to make that
be-all and end-all of open access and
when opponents make that move I would
ask you to call them on it because it is
not it is not an adequate move it is not
an adequate response but Public Library
of Science is one of the leading science
journals that has made this move its
research articles have been reported in
the New York Times and covered it's
cutting edge research that is published
funded by authors grants made available
immediately on the web a thoroughly
peer-reviewed very prestigious at
editorial board and the like another one
that's important because humanities
folks say well I don't get grants so how
you how am I gonna do that
well the University of Michigan is has
come up with one model where we can fund
the journal off the feet overhead fumes
of the library if you can read up there
it's edited by philosophers published by
librarians free on the web right there's
no cost to the author to submit there's
no cost to the reader because you've
just got an in-house editorial board
peer reviewers are all working for free
you can really push the cost down
when you're doing a digital only
publication and so there are existing
models proofs of concept that open at
this form of open access is viable even
in the humanities without grant funding
okay
I think I've run a little over time so I
just want to leave you with the
assignment you've got to read existing
copyright agreements make sure you look
at what reader or what rights the author
has because to their credit some
publishers already divide the rights
along the ways that Kenny had suggested
they give the author the right to put
their final manuscript up on their own
website or maybe even on the in the
Columbia digital repository if you have
those rights exorcise them right if you
don't have those rights negotiate to get
them
I've written some standardized authors
addendum that you can just stick to the
author's contract and I'll be happy to
supply the links to those and we can
make those part of the record here if if
no but also in the future consider the
access policies of the place that you're
publishing all right figure out I don't
want to go through that hassle later on
so if you have two equivalent journals
in terms of reputation choose the one
that's got the better access policies to
submit to favor that lets and there are
a few other things to do and I'm going
to turn it over to Heather because it's
time to move from the Saturday going to
the dump to figure out how we're going
to institutionalize these better
information practices and there's action
happening there are a number of
institutions funding institutions
Harvard the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
has come together to act institutionally
and Heather's going to bring us up to
speed on all of those developments so
thanks very much I'm intimidated
appropriately intimidated and inspired
by the first two speakers so hopefully
what I'll be able to at least attempt to
do in my time
here is a use the mouse properly and
almost there there we go
and reiterate some points that both
Kenny and Mike made and then also give
you a little bit more concrete guidance
on okay now how can I go ahead and do
the kinds of things that there that both
Kenny and Mike suggested that I do to
adequately manage my copyright to ensure
that the results of my research or my
scholarship has the broadest possible
downstream use distribution and reuse
that I want it to have in the future and
as Ken mentioned the organization that I
represent is called the scholarly
publishing and academic resources
coalition which is why we always go by
the acronym spark even I can't remember
that as a full name on most even on my
best days what spark is is essentially a
library membership organization that was
founded about 10 years ago and it was
founded to be a catalyst for action to
try to find concrete actions that
scholars the library community and the
Academy as a whole could take together
to move from the current status quo of a
system that still mired in so much of
the ecology as Mike said of a
paper-based communication system and to
try to move it to take advantage of the
tremendous opportunities that are
provided by this new digital networked
environment that we have and I want to
be really clear the spark as you can see
from our homepage open access advocates
the idea that we're working towards is
the idea that Mike described we believe
that scholarship should move to a form
where the distribution of scholarship is
freely available on the internet and
we're talking about that that subset of
scholarship and science that researchers
and scholars have traditionally produced
without expectation of payment right
very important we're talking about
journal articles monographs where
authors have been unpaid and we would
like to see that kind of scholarship the
ownership of that scholarship and the
distribution of that scholarship be put
more closely back into the hands of the
scholars that produce it so that you can
control it's its downstream destiny as
best as you can
we're not talking about
this issue as an issue that's punitive
to publishers right there are a lot of
publishers that are kind of coming along
in this in this world and trying to make
this happen right trying to enable the
broadest downstream distribution and
reuse of this material so when we're
talking about this I want to emphasize
that we talked about exercising
understanding exercising and managing
your copyright as a way to leverage the
opportunities that are put in front of
us by the internet allowing us to
distribute our scholarship to a much
broader audience at but then we ever
would have felt possible at virtually no
marginal costs for each additional issue
we don't have to worry about press setup
and paper mail and binding shipping
charges all over the world anymore and
yet we still think about that we're
still stuck in a system that has so many
of those little vestiges in in in
different parts of our scholarly
communication system so we're talking
about really coming out this problem
from from the the time when a scholarly
article is created it's pretty
incredible that you know 15 years after
the internet really has been in popular
use we see that scholarly research
articles are still so often only
available to a small fraction of the
community of potential users and the
reason why is no secret Mike did a good
job I think of describing the fact that
scholarly journal prices scarlet
journals are expensive and particularly
in science technology and medicine I
didn't put a slide in that that I
normally do because the slides getting a
little bit outdated but it shows a 20
year history of journal price increases
compared to the Consumer Price Index and
I realized I don't actually need to put
the slide in because I can do this and I
call this my open access modern
interpretive dance the the journal price
line on the slide looks like this it
goes straight up in the air and over a
20-year period it increases at about 260
percent and then the consumer price
index at the same time it goes like this
sort of off into the distance as a nice
sort of steady 41 percent what we have
in the middle here dance part for the
show is a gap in access where people
cannot afford when your library budgets
are going up to keep
with the with the rate of inflation and
journal prices are going up at this rate
you can't afford access to all the
materials you want to provide your
audience what ends up happening is that
means your work isn't being read isn't
being seen isn't being used by the
amount of people that you want it to be
seen by so the result has been for this
really this new kind of framework that
allows us to take these access barriers
down to let these people in the middle
get access to the work that you've
created and to allow your work to be not
just accessed as freely as possible but
also to be more fully used so how do you
go about ensuring that your work can be
accessed and used more as fully as
possible well I think you know Mike
started to give you a laundry list at
the end of his talk about things that
you should do reading the copyright
transfer form for a journal understand
before you make a decision in which
journal that you want to publish your
article is the most important step and
the copyright transfer agreements tend
to look like this they're you know one
to two pages they have very basic
components if you look at them and you
you want help in dissecting what does
this thing actually say what I really am
interested in doing is being able to put
a copy of my article after it's
published on my own website or in my
institution's repository or my funding
agency says I need to do something and
specific with my article how can I
figure out you know what this copyright
transfer form actually says well reading
it you know is always step one I'm not a
lawyer sometimes I get stalked on these
copyright transfer forms and I was a
journal publisher for 15 years so I
would suggest that there are resources
available on the web to help you
interpret these the thing is just
zipping along to help you interpret what
these copyright forms are actually
asking you to do so there's a resource
for example called the sherpa/romeo
website and this is a compendium of
publisher copyright policies and if you
take a look at it you can search for the
journal your considerable considering
publishing in and it will tell you if
it's got a little green checkmark it
allows you to archive or to post on a
website a preprint
of the article that you want to publish
or a final copy of that article
say you are it just keeps hopping along
here say you are a physicist and you're
interested in publishing in one of the
journals of the American Physical
Society well this looks pretty good you
go to sherpa/romeo you type in American
Physical Society and this tells you this
publishers got some pretty good practice
practices it allows you to post that
preprint that post print it's compliant
with loads of the policies that
intersect with copyright in that
discipline it's great it's free to read
you could take click on the view policy
and see what the policy actually looks
like that's terrific
say you are however a sorry you would
think I never used technology before but
say however you want to publish in a
journal for the American Psychological
Association you type in American
Psychological Association and then
you'll see well there are a few things
you can do there are lots of things that
you can't do with this article
lots of policies and things that
intersect with what you may want to do
with this article down the pike that you
see big red X's through so this site is
a really good way to help you as an
individual author understand what's
possible to do with what it is possible
to do with your article once you decide
to publish in a specific journal versus
another journal if you're one of the you
know the unlucky authors who says well
gosh you know I got a grant from HHMI
the Howard Hughes Medical Institute and
I want to really wanted to publish in
the Journal of Clinical Psychology for
example but oh there's a red X through
my D HHMI notice that says that the APA
will not allow me to comply with what
HHMI wants me to do which is actually to
take a copy of my final manuscript and
make it publicly accessible by a
publicly open repository what do I do
what can I you know what are my options
there well of course your options could
be to look for another journal but say
this is the journal you really want to
publish it you're not stuck you can
actually consider doing another thing
that might suggest it at the end of his
talk you can consider amending that
copyright transfer form right Kenny was
very clear and saying copyright is a
contract
it's something that can be negotiated it
can be amended there are lots of tools
out there for individual authors to turn
to to say okay I really want to be in
this APA journal but you know I've got
an HHMI grant and I need to do something
and something specific you can look at
the science Commons website you can look
at the SPARC website you can do a google
search for something called an author
addendum and on all of those sites
you'll find legally vetted tools that
are just little pieces of virtual paper
that you can use to append to any
traditional journal transfer copyright
agreement that's that you can say I
simply want out transfer all of my
copyrights I simply want to reserve the
right to be able to post a copy of my
final paper in the HHMI required website
or any one of the other rights that you
might want to reserve the point is there
are these tools available in multiple
forms for you to use the science Commons
website I'm going to recommend not over
the SPARC website but I think the
science Commons what website has a
really great little online addendum
generator where you can type in what it
is you want to reserve the right to do
and it will customize and generate an
addenda for you to use in these in these
circumstances so that's one reason I
think that it's important for for us to
pay attention to to copyright right you
you want to make sure your your you have
the the best choice of journal outlets
to publish in you want to make sure this
work gets out there and what's more or
can you and we are operating in an
environment which is moving more towards
the the green environment that Mike
envisions and that you know we do live
in now or we live more in in the
recycling era it within scholarship our
academic institutions are recognizing
that that access gap right well you know
it seems like these are just numbers
right the journals are expensive
and you know they're increasing at a
rate that doesn't keep pace with
inflation yeah it's not a great thing
that scholars don't have access to it
but what does it really matter
universities are increasingly
recognizing that it matters a whole lot
that it's really affecting the core
mission of academic universities and
institutions of higher education which
is to disseminate and convey knowledge
but if people can't get access to the
intellectual output of your University
then the university is in achieving its
core goal so what we're seeing happening
is that universities are actually taking
action and they're taking action around
making sure that they're closing this
gap that they're they're narrowing this
this gap of people's ability to access
this information and that they're also
boosting their position to be able to
bring forward the results of the
intellectual work done on their campuses
to as wide a world as possible
Mike noted that Harvard University was
one example of this and I do want to to
say Harvard is the first example of this
last February the Faculty of the College
of Arts and Sciences of Harvard
University voted to essentially make
open access the default mode on campus
and they went about doing this and in
terms of putting a requirement that any
faculty member in the College of Arts
and Sciences that produces a scholarly
article agrees that the university that
they and the University will retain a
non exclusive right to distribute that
article via Harvard University is
digital repository so they're
essentially looking at this as a
permissions mandate right retaining the
copyright on campus to ensure that the
works of all of the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences at Harvard is distributed in
these digital repositories to the widest
possible audience
the lovely picture is Stewart Schieber
who is the faculty leader who helped
develop the policy and push this vote
through the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
on Harvard's campus the law school and
the
it's the other school Kennedy School of
Business thank you for government just
have followed suit Stanford University's
School of Education has passed a similar
policy MIT just a couple of weeks ago
passed a similar resolution Boston
University has put a recommendation for
their faculty to consider doing the same
thing Texas A&M Overland College Trinity
University these discussions are going
on on all of these campuses about taking
a similar role in terms of a permissions
mandate copyright Center to ensure that
the intellectual output of the faculty
on campus has that broadest possible
downstream life and the other reason
that the copyright is important to you
is in sort of a larger you know sort of
more global ecology is that it's not
just campuses who are recognizing not
just institutions of higher education
that are recognizing that this is a
powerful tool for ensuring that our
research gets out there increasingly
we're seeing public funding agencies and
private funding agencies but public
funding agencies is specific moving
towards in implementing policies that
use copyright and the retention of
copyright and the requirement for
depositing a manuscript and article in
an openly accessible repository at the
center of their policies to be able to
maximize are their investment in
scientific and scholarly research and
this is just a quote that encapsulates
the the policy discussion that's been
going on all over the globe this came
from the international organization from
for Economic Cooperation and Development
the OECD that noted in back in 2005 when
they were looking at this idea of how do
you how do you how do you ensure that
the research that you're investing in
that that investment is leveraged to its
fullest possible extent they realized
you could do that by doing one very
simple thing by ensuring that the
results of that research can reach the
broadest possible audience so that it
can be built on right it's just a
explicit recognition of the cumulative
nature of scholarship and of research
right we can only advance our
disciplines and only leverage our
investments in science and scholarship
if what came before is available for
this generation and the next generation
of scholars to build on and so we've
seen very visible iterations of this
kind of thinking come out in the last
couple of years most notably in the
United States we see the largest public
funder of research the National
Institutes of Health which has a twenty
nine billion dollar annual research
budget now have a requirement that if
you as a researcher take grant money
from the NIH you are required to do two
things one to make sure you retain
sufficient rights to comply with the
policy to know upfront that if I take
this money from NIH I'm going to be
required to deposit the final version of
any article accepted for publication in
a peer-reviewed journal into an open
access to a digital repository at NIH
right so it's again the twofold thing a
permission mandate this one's more of a
deposit mandate with a little permission
function on it but again centering
around making sure that you as the
grantee are aware when you're writing
that article and submitting it then in
order to be in compliance and to give
this research the life that it deserves
that you successfully manage your
copyright and finally let me actually
say that finally I'm going to talk a
little bit about why it's important in
terms of how to characterize this in a
in a politically correct way not
everyone agrees that the open access
world is the world that we should be
moving towards and in particular the
journal publishers who have
traditionally charged extremely high
subscription prices right that have us
up here in the stratosphere have fought
very hard against the idea of this broad
distribution not because they're against
the idea of broad distribution but
because this broad distribution cuts
into the profits that they have for
their exclusive perpetual distribution
license to your work right right now
there's no way in a
version based environment for anybody to
get access to the results of most
commercially published research without
paying a subscription fee or an access
fee now and into perpetuity in an open
access world that barrier is removed and
so the ability of publishers to reap
these large profits into perpetuity is
limited severely but what we're seeing
is because scholarly publishing is such
big business we're talking about profit
margins that that reap publishers
particularly in STM upwards of six to
seven billion dollars in revenue per
year billion with the be it's huge
business so market analysts cover the
scholarly publishing marketplace quite
thoroughly and they've recognized that
there is really as a battle going on
right now where policies on the one hand
like the Harvard policy and the NIH
policy are coming out that are
encouraging authors to to manage their
copyrights in a way that makes their
work more openly accessible but on the
other hand there's a pushback from the
publishing industry to try to keep hold
keep control of these copyrights this
systems working very well for commercial
publishers thank you very much and they
don't want to change it X and BNP
paribas for example last year in an
analysis of the scholarly journal
marketplace noted something that I think
is really important and shows why
copyright is really at the center of
this battle for control over
dissemination they noted that in their
view the economic model of journal
publishing is really based on selling
access to an aggregate of non
proprietary academic content and they
understand that while if you sign it
over the publishers on the exclusive
publishing rights of scientists work we
don't share the view that they own the
intellectual property of that work you
would think that that would be pretty
obvious right well unfortunately there's
a bill in front of Congress right now
called HR 801 that would actually amend
copyright law that would create a new
class of copyright protected works
largely in favor of the publishers that
would that that that says that if an
article has been essentially undergone
the peer-review process that the
publishers can claim ownership copyright
ownership of the article even early
in the process so there's a this is a
really active area and it's a really
important area for scholars to be aware
and involved and actively engaged in
learning as much as you can about how
best to ensure that you're I'm a mom so
I always come kind of come back to this
analogy that you know Mike talks about
the copyright being showered down upon
you I always think I'm you know you
produced this article it's kind of like
you're putting your baby out there in
the world right your little research
article out there in the world and you
want to make sure that all the
possibilities in the world are available
to that your baby as it grows up in the
world that I mean I think of scholarly
articles I know it's corny
I think of scholarly articles in that
regard too so I think you know my my
takeaway from this would be to tip for
us to be conscious producers of the
articles that we're putting out there
and to think about ways the actions you
can take from the inception of that
article to ensure that your scholarship
can be accessed and then used in all of
the ways you might envision for not only
yourself but for future generations of
scholars I'll close with by just putting
a screen up here in the introduction I
was noted that I am the executive
director of spark spark also convenes a
larger umbrella group of people who are
interested in the idea of open access
but from the public perspective if
you're interested in looking at any kind
of political activity around in ensuring
that bills like HR 801 don't get off the
ground you can take a look at the ATA
website we work specifically on the
subset of scott scholarship and research
that's been funded use it using taxpayer
dollars so I'll stop there because I
know we have probably have loads of
questions from the audience on this
well they're getting set up to answer
questions I want to point out that it's
important remember that these things are
not mutually exclusive you can still get
an income stream even though you're
putting stuff out in a repository for
example I was just looking at the books
of a small law journal in law school and
even though they basically published by
putting out putting material on a
website they also allow aggregators to
take their material and serve it up
through their aggregator services and
they get a quarter of their income
through royalties from that process and
so the notion that one kills the other
is a totally false overstated notion I
think so questions for the panelists
what is the to stop inflation
anybody good well yeah I mean you do
realize that's a totally different
question from everything we've been
talking about realize that it's relevant
yeah tell me tell me tell me what you're
thinking others please help me out here
tell me what you're thinking of
I have nothing what is that can you give
us an example of what it concerns you
yeah yeah go ahead suppose a certain
scholar writes an article or a book but
the work is published
perhaps after leaving the university and
then somebody else takes on us the same
position that the scholar had perhaps
uses her name or
but anyway or in fact I mean that's
that's just a risk that exists in the
scholarly environment and nothing
so that risk doesn't change whether the
access is open or not again I would
argue if we had machine access to the
literature we could actually use the
machines to help detect that kind of
plagiarism better which is what the
Turnitin service tries to do with
student plagiarism so again that would
for me be an argument for web you know
if we had a web 2.0 environment
information environment we'd have tools
to help deal with that problem better
but I don't think I don't think open
access I do think it's sort of
orthogonal to what we're talking about
here and and and I'll just have it add a
little bit to to frame the issue you
know if they couldn't pick it up on the
camera the the question was about
plagiarism and identity theft
extraordinarily important issues
starting with plagiarism plain
plagiarism is the issue as you did
described in your situation in your
example of an example a situation
involving fundamentally not giving
credit where credit is due and that
really is separate just to get to some
of the structure of the issues it's
separate from copyright in that
copyright is about the rights associated
with reproduction etc of of the work not
necessarily with identifying the source
of the work and so identifying the
source is extremely important it's
fundamental in the academic environment
yes you may thank you regarding Michael
Carroll use of machine code also
increases opportunities
these terrorists I don't think thank you
very much
hi my question is basically I know many
universities have issued statements
saying they take the position that
academics own the copyright in their
scholarly works but from what dr. Cruz
you're saying it's not clear to me that
that is able to override the
work-for-hire clause in the Copyright
Act and that universities do not
actually own the copyrights so this is
great you asked a brilliant question and
it really really is a complicated issue
in an ideal world you you are absolutely
right if if that work pick anything a
scholarly article teaching materials a
lab report pick anything that is
copyrightable that's created by any one
of us that if it is work for hire let's
just take that if to avoid the details
if it's work for hire can we as I
outlined transfer that copyright back to
the individual author and the answer is
yes we can but but you're quite right I
I moved quickly through it and I think
you caught it that that a transfer of
the copyright really must be in a
writing signed by the party doing the
transferring which leaves open for
future debate litigation lawyers making
lots of money that the the the question
of well wait a minute does that policy
in the policy manual really accomplish
what it purports to do and we do have
some court cases on that that
that are really emphasizing it that
question we do need to take a fresh look
and I would say this and I have said
this to individuals to universities if
you've got something that you really
need to nail down and you see dispute on
the horizon there's enough at stake you
better get the parties at the table
write it down and get them to sign it
yeah that is that realistic in the
routine environment no but and and our
people likely to dispute that in the
routine case no but if you've got the
not routine situation you better get the
parties to the table and write it up and
sign it yeah it's a from the lawyers
perspective this is an interesting
situation because the entire discussion
is built on a very rickety foundation
and it's basically because there was a
change in copyright law prior to 1976
the work-for-hire doctrines had a
teacher exception where the because the
work-for-hire lease be attached yeah
well they're the courts had created the
doctrine and so they could create their
own exceptions so there was a lot of
fluidity in it and then in 1976 Congress
says we're gonna write it down and they
wrote it down just saying if you're an
employee it's in the scope of employment
the your employer is the author so as
long as we would agree that a scholar
writing an article is in the scope of
employment then the flat text of the law
says the university owns it but lawyers
we have interpretive methodologies and
we can write so it's not at all clear
that that's actually what the law is and
it's unlikely that any party and the
system as it's currently configured has
the incentive to bring this to court and
seek a final resolution but there is a
potential ticking time bomb under the
whole scholarly journal publication
right it imagines suddenly the Supreme
Court rules universities own the
copyrights of every Journal article ever
written by their researchers that's it
that's it's it's a theoretical
possibility but the possibility of that
ever becoming someone investigating and
investing in the litigation I just don't
see it happening
and you know what would be great but the
result of that though is suddenly all
those copyright transfers signed by
authors would now be potentially ruled
invalid and and now we would just blow
up the copyright ownership at the entire
system that'd be kind of fun
I'm sensing a weekend project for Kenny
in the future
I've got nothing else to do but you
sweep the floor
hi I have a couple of questions the
first is how does any of this apply to
graduate students in the university so
for instance if you produce something
and you know or let's let's assume that
there's some going to be some kind of
tension between the work-for-hire
concept and you know author or ownership
right does it also apply to graduate
students since they're technically not
university employees that's question one
the second is especially for journals
that have like some of the ones you were
showing that have less favorable
copyright contracts with the author than
ApS journals what happens with software
so suppose you've written a piece of
scientific software that you intend to
distribute is open source but you
describe the algorithm and maybe even
pieces of the code itself in a journal
article that you then you know submit to
a journal that has less favorable
copyright agreements what Trump's well
you employee the institution you should
probably talk about the PAL give it a
try I'll give it a try but under the
policy are you allowed to make that
decision right if and when we talk when
we talk about the policy the quota to
get to the what I think is the kernel of
the question if if your article your
copy right protected article includes
lines of software code who owns what
with respect to those that software code
once that work has been published you
know I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give
you the most important answer I can
upfront you want to know what it is it
depends what your contract says how's
that so so you've got a situation that I
would say you need a very carefully
written contract before you publish that
article get the answer you want laid out
in that contract now let's put that
aside for a second there would be the
better
sir and under a typical arrangement you
know those the copyright in your article
itself explaining the code is going to
be yours under at least the policy if
not under the law then maybe you've
transferred that over to the publisher I
hope you haven't but maybe you have so
what we're talking about in all of that
is the copyright what about if the lines
of code which could be copyright of all
and maybe they've now flowed with the
article but they might be patentable in
that case if you you have a patentable
invention that you create here at the
University even though it's articulated
inside of a copyright of all article you
have a duty to disclose that to the
proper office the technology transfer or
other proper office at your your own
university so you would disclose that
there and that would be sorted out in a
typical publication agreement especially
in the science field it will say many of
them say even though you're transferring
the copyright or something equally
overreaching we still leave with you the
patents so patents are often singled out
in these agreements and left with you
and then if you're part of the
university you're duty-bound to report
that to the University that's your
typical way that those pieces would flow
I hope that's helpful
Yeah right
hang on hang on hang on more detail than
I can handle this and I don't think
everyone heard so the thing is they're
too copyrighted works here that are then
mixed there's the copyright in the soft
so problem is the software is both
potentially patentable and a copyrighted
work let's just talk about it as a
copyrighted work of authorship and then
there's the copyright in the in the
article but the article reports a little
bit of this as well right so this is an
open source that means it's under a
copyright license that says you can do
anything with this subject - so are you
doing GPL BS ok so it's under a
copyright license that basically says
you can do anything you want with this
but if you make a derivative work from
it you have to license your derivative
work under the same license you took my
pieces of code from so it's an open
license it says take it go for it but
now if I put that into this copyright at
work and I tell the publisher I'm giving
you the rights to this copyright at work
that's got these few pieces that are
already licensed under different terms
now there's a potential conflict between
the copyright terms of this work and the
copyright terms of this work it
definitely depends on what the
publishers agreement says depends on how
many lines of code I mean because
they're exceptions it's so that if it's
only a few lines of code and it's the
algorithm you know it's not clear that
this that that that's even enough
copyrightable expression to trigger the
problem you've posed but it is it is the
problem that the more general problem of
I've written this work I own a copyright
in my expression but the total amount of
expression includes stuff from other
places so art history has this problem
all the time right of what do we do and
and usually the publishers in those
disciplines have in their agreements
some clearance you know you you
represent that I cleared the rights and
in this case you're the both copyright
owners so you say yeah I got the rights
from this guy to publish it in here
that's exactly right and and if you're
talking about including those lines than
in your article I mean remember I
mentioned third party material at some
point in the presentation yours is like
that in some ways it's a little
different from a quotation from another
source except it just happens to be
governed by a license term that makes it
open source which is even better you
know because then you may not have to
worry about fair use or anything else
it's already allowed for public
disclosure fine
well you I mean so it's it's the same
rickety foundation except now you're not
but I think it's it's stronger that you
you must own the copyright unless I mean
the university might design have a
policy that says we get a license but I
don't think that they can claim
ownership in any way even you would
really depend on your question was about
you write an article in your capacity as
a graduate student if if if it's if
you're not writing it in your capacity
as an employee or subject to any other
contractual obligation with respect to
that work then it's really going to be
yours I mean if you're saying I'm a
graduate student and I wrote this
article or paper as part of my
requirements of earning my degree that's
why I wrote it it's yours it's yours so
it's up to you to manage as you see fit
subject to the patent policy I mean
because anytime you write an article if
that discloses a potentially patentable
invention most universities have it have
a policy that governs that that requires
even graduate students to disclose that
to the universe the university may claim
patent ownership but that's like a
separate panel
exactly yeah big issue was there a
question was
is it on I don't have a question about
terrorism it's hard ACTA fine
I wonder if we could drill down on this
work for a higher concept I imagine you
don't have to be an employee to be doing
a work for hire you could be a
consultant I imagine you could be
writing something without being paid at
all if you are writing for a scholarly
journal or something like that or an
association and there's some kind of a
quid pro quo we're so glad you stopped
now everybody pull out your books for a
responsive reading is it out the there's
a there's a there's a fairly
straightforward answer to your question
there are two varieties of work for hire
one is occurs far far far more often
than the other and so that's the only
one that we've mentioned so far and that
is am I an employee not an independent
contractor not a volunteer am I an
employee acting within the scope of my
employment now lawyers have made a lot
of money debating what those words mean
but those are the words and if your
answer is yes I'm an employee yes it was
within the scope of my employment to
write that piece create that work
produce that website it's worked for
hire unless there's a teacher acceptor
then there's a second variety of work
for hire that does apply to independent
contractors so now we brought somebody
in gave them X number of dollars said
produce this website and go away that's
an independent contractor to come in get
the job done and leave and but the the
work for hire in that
text applies only very narrowly the
first thing you have to have remember
the first one was employee within the
scope of employment that means it could
become work for hire by circumstance and
presto its work for hire you weren't
thinking of anything but it was because
you fit in the category but the second
one where it's an independent contractor
you can't get into it by accident
it requires a written agreement signed
by both parties that includes the magic
language that this will be a work made
for hire you can't get there by accident
so which means when you hire that person
to come in and do your video production
your website development your software
development whatever it might be you
better and you want it to be a work for
hire you better get an agreement that
has the magic language plus to make it
even narrower it only applies to certain
types of works that are on the list in
the statute and there's a really good
chance your work is not on that list so
you can't make it work for hire even if
you tried so what do you do then a
transfer of the copyright if that's what
you want or a license of the copyright
if that's what you want so you're back
to a management issue about how to
manage the or the the the the copyright
and the bundle of Rights and how do we
get to a good equitable result out of
all of this that's where we should be
headed just one quick thing because
sometimes people work for hire just
means the author the employer gets
treated as the author but but it could
also I mean you can also just give away
or assign the the copyright in either
case the employer owns everything now
their differences down the line about
what happens depending on those legal
treatments but for but an important
point is in either case in the
independent contractor case or the
transfer of copyright you do need a
written agreement signed by the author
so one way to do output open access
through the backdoor is passive
right you just don't sign the publishers
agreement what's the legal effect of not
doing that is you actually retain the
exclusive rights you can't give the
publisher exclusive rights except
through a written agreement so they
never ask you if they never pressed the
question and you never sign it the
publisher has a non-exclusive license to
they have your permission by conduct
because permission is easy to grant
exclusive rights are difficult to grant
that's the design of the statute to make
sure the author is consciously let the
world know that this is a transfer so in
that second category of work for hire
you need the signed agreement as well so
either by transfer or by work for hire
outside the employment context you need
a signed writing in order to give
exclusive rights to another party I have
a question I have a question for spark
here's here's the question that that we
get in faculty meetings all over the
university talking about these issues
and I'm eager to hear your response
common question isn't this open access
movement going to kill my favorite
journals isn't it going to be the death
of the journals that we're counting on
as important vehicle of communication as
an important standard of quality in the
in the scholarship of my field so so we
get that question all the time right we
got that question from faculty members
we get that question from publishers we
get that questions and members of
Congress and the answer is no I mean
there's nothing in than the the model or
the models that can support a transition
to open access publishing that will say
traditional journals can't make a
transition from a subscription-based
model to an open access based model or
the new journals that are just as
prestigious and just as rigorous in
terms of quality control can't be
created you know born out of the born
into an open access model the the real
worry that I think publishers have and I
think publishers have a legitimate real
when they're talking about transitioning
from subscription access to to open
access is they've relied on a model of
doing business for you know many of them
for multiple decades the the mode of
journal publishing has moved from a
balanced portfolio approach to reprimand
new stream supporting a journal to the
vast majority of revenue for any
individual journal upwards of 85 to 90
percent of the revenue that supports the
average scholarly journal comes from
institutional library subscriptions so
publishers have really moved into this
putting all of their financial eggs in
one basket and the basket comes out of
off the backs of libraries so whenever
you're talking about moving to a model
that says we're not going to collect
subscription money and ninety percent of
my revenue is coming from subscription
money you can see why publishers panic I
mean why we are the concern is what the
heck do we do the reality is that there
are lots of different kinds of revenue
streams that some journal publishers do
employ and that most journal publishers
can employ in order to support an open
access model a lot of journals scholarly
journals for better or for worse
employee author charges whether their
submission fees for a journal page
charges for a journal charges for you
know any any kind of a service that the
journal provides that an author would
value would be willing to to pay some
money for either out of their grant or
individually a lot of journals
particularly general interest journals
that are heavily trafficked get revenue
from advertising that's another little
slice of the pie that can can be used to
support it some open access journals and
traditional journals employ sponsorships
from commercial companies there's a
large sort of number of little sources
of income that can be used to supplement
the money that comes from the current
university library slice of the pie what
we're seeing in terms of the sort of
maturation of business models that are
that are being employed to support the
open access movement is
but the funders of basic research the
people who are paying money to do the
experiments in the first place
are beginning to explicitly recognize
and to state if I fund you to do an
experiment or to do this scholarship and
you can't don't or won't communicate the
results of what you found that
experiment is really only half done and
I really haven't gotten what I've paid
for out of this out of this investment
in the research so a lot of funders are
explicitly now starting to set aside
money for the communication of the
results and that can be employed and
deployed in you know lots of different
ways however a publisher wants to
collect it through an author fee or a
sponsorship fee that's another that's a
pot of money that can be used we also
see institutions like Harvard that are
saying if we're going to require write
if we're going to require our faculty
members or if our faculty members are
telling us is a more accurate read of
that that they want their material to be
available in open access outlets then we
as an academic institution not just a
library but an academic institution are
going to look into creating a fund that
comes out of the institution for helping
to support the distribution and an open
access model of our scholarship so begin
to see the little threads being woven
together into the safety net that can
support an open access system some will
some journals not make the transition
successfully yes I mean I think that's
reality that this is a seismic shift in
a market where there are strong players
and weak players some of the weaker
players will not make the transition
successfully but there but I don't think
there will be a mass extinction of
journals because of some fatal flaw in
economic models potential economic
models to support the open access
movement if I can add to that a little
bit there were lots of librarians who
would love to see lots of journals time
there are a lot of journals that I
didn't say that I want you to know
pointless and publishing stuff that have
been rejected by other journals and so
if in fact we do have a Precambrian data
whatever you want to call it
one thing I think is really important
that that's happening now like I do I
usually do talks about open access not
just strictly copyright and when I talk
about open access I talk about the the
point where we are right now you know
six years ago seven years ago we started
talking about open access as a concept
and we've moved from this sort of
theoretical construct of wouldn't it be
nice if where there was a handful of
open access journal publishing outlets
for for authors to publish in and a
couple of digital repositories if you
couldn't find when you couldn't find a
journal publishing outlet to put your
manuscripts in there's a directory of
open access journals that now lists
4,000 open access journals and
disciplines from you know a to Z from
countries around the world there's more
than 1300 open access digital
repositories if you just want your
article to be openly accessible and you
don't want to go through the open access
publishing outlet and yet when I give
those statistics a lot of times on
campuses one of the questions I get back
from faculty members members are well
those 4,000 journals how many of them
are really good and you know I turn
around this well how many subscription
access journals are really good you look
at the ecosystem we're starting to build
a parallel one in the open access world
where it's caveat emptor you need to do
your research you do your research on
the journal look at the editorial board
exactly what you would do in a
subscription-based environment to make
your choice but the point is we have a
choice now so it you know sort of five
and a half six short years we've gone
from just a few to really this parallel
universe that's on the verge of you know
merging with the subscription
environment and hopefully overtaking it
Kenny I just got a bill about two weeks
ago for a journal that's especially it
says for Financial Analysts that we get
to the law school library now this is a
field that has basically led us down a
very bizarre path and contributed to the
depression that we're in now and they
are asking for sixty six percent or for
next year subscription to Wow you know I
would dearly love to say if I didn't
have this being routed to a couple of
professors I would say to hell let's
just cut them off now
let them receive a signal I have asked
questions at law law librarian
Association meetings saying when are you
going to cancel the journals or the
books that only five people are buying
nothing seems to make publishers think
that they should stop publishing
something and that's what I would love
to see happen right is some publishers
say this just isn't worth it anymore
well you know I worked for Elsevier
science that's my one disclosure I
worked for Elsevier for 11 months I want
you to know out of my 15 year publishing
career in the not-for-profit world and
I'd quit Elsevier because that the
business model there is something that
would make us kill journals the business
model for journals my title was
acquisitions editor so I thought you
know maybe I'm here to start up new
journals but I find new to buy new
journals buy new journals was the
operative mode I had a list of
spreadsheets of 11 journals that were
all munched together and of those 11
journals those spreadsheets
I had a target revenue number that I had
to make at the end of the year my
revenue number on these journals these
11 journals it was like 3.6 million
dollars
these were linear algebra and
experimental math journals what I had to
do was try to find a way to manage these
journals to make that margin at the end
of the year and if I didn't make the
margin I didn't have a job so what what
do you do to make that margin will you
look for ways to cut the manufacturing
costs of the journal or to bring in more
money when you only have one source of
revenue the only way to bring in more
money is to raise the library
subscriptions so the dance was which
journal were you going to raise by what
percent you know in your collection of
11 and where were you going to skimp or
scrape or save money and manufacturing
costs from doing everything like print
more words on a page so the gutter width
in the middle the journal I we try to
squeeze as small as I could cheaper
paper you know less get the authors to
print fewer pages and their articles and
that was really the dance it was try to
save money on the manufacturing end and
then make up what you couldn't
save by charging libraries more and the
the net effect on the journals would be
that the higher I raise the prices the
fewer subscribers I would have and when
my subscriber base got down to which
many of them did 300 that was a little
red flag that would come up in your
computer system and it would say now
you're supposed to go out and look for a
new an organization a society or a group
of editors that would be willing to
start up a new journal because that
one's gonna die it was a death spiral
model of journal publishing and that was
what I was expected to do as a publisher
I mean I cried and I also started doing
this because that's not a model that
served scholarship you know you price
people out of the marketplace
and we have our access gap you know as
we price people out but you also kill
perfectly good scholarly vehicles that
way so I want to ask a question of the
audience because I want to understand
Columbia University in this in this
environment is this university that's
interested in than having a leadership
position here because Jim Neil the
University Librarian has been one of the
most forward-thinking folks on open
access so the University Libraries here
have gotten this for a long time and it
gotten this it's not just about
subscription fee it's about what is the
role of the University and why is open
access an essential part of the
university in the 21st century so it's
that level of vision that this
institution has had but I don't sense
that the faculty where's the faculty on
this and I mean younger folks in the
audience do you expect to mature into a
professional environment in which your
output is going to be put only into
walled gardens you're not gonna be
sharing in a social aren't you gonna
want to have some kind of social media
tools to enhance your scholarly
communication and where is that isn't
this an institution that's supposed to
be breeding leaders where's the
leadership here on this campus I mean we
need a champion here the Stewart Seaver
made it happen at Harvard he was one of
those guys taking his scholar his
scholarship to the recycling center on
Saturdays he was rewriting copyright
agreements himself and
we came along and said Stuart here I'm a
lawyer
try this he said fine thank you started
using the addenda but he was doing the
hard work of going back and forth
one-on-one with publishers because he
knew he was a computer scientist and he
knew what the future is he know about
how important machinery access to the
open literature is for his his work in
his discipline and so what's going on
here I mean the problem is you know
you're inside the privileged world guard
garden and you say I don't have an
access problem right now we did find one
resource it's on the computer where you
do have an access problem there is one
nature publication that you even at
Columbia University don't have access to
the other dirty secret in the Academy
right is I don't have an access problem
because if I find an abstract on the web
and my library doesn't have it I'll send
an email to the author and they'll send
me their paper right because they're my
peer and that's peer to peer
file-sharing right there's a black
market in PDFs that takes the pressure
off the access problem if you're in the
club right but where's leadership here
what I mean it's time we've been doing
this for too long it's getting old it's
time to wake up to the possibility
because it's again it's an opportunity
story I mean the publishers are seeing
it as a threat story the more advanced
publishers including Elsevier know that
they're playing the endgame on the
walled garden strategy they know what
the future is is an open code based of
text on which you add value added
services where we can start linking the
text to the data to the models all right
that's the future of scholarly
communication and they've got their
little research and development weighing
working on that and meanwhile the
scholarly societies are blind to this
for the most part and it's really time
to have that conversation it's getting
you know we're wasting time here we have
all these great digital tools that are
not being deployed in the one area where
they can have the most social socially
beneficial impact so I guess I want to
ask the audience what's going on what do
we where's our champion what do we need
to do to
to move the conversation on this campus
more because we got you know Jim helped
recruit Kenny Kenny's a great resource
for this institution and I understand
he's been having a lot of conversations
but it really is time to step up to the
plate Columbia I mean I'm serious
Harvard's up there MIT how long do you
want to wait you want to let Cornell go
next because their conversations there
you know who's the first New York
institution to step up to the plate and
have an institutional policy on open
access and you can add University of
Illinois which we're hearing about may
be on the brink of another similar kind
of open access resolution every there's
sort of a partial answer to your
question and we have been working with
faculty diligently to raise awareness
about this issue meeting meeting with
faculty at their departments engaging in
very much these same kind of discussions
there's individual leadership within the
different departments one of the
challenges of our cultural environment
of Columbia is we have very little means
for one department to talk to the other
we don't we don't have a faculty Senate
we don't have a forum for communication
across the university so we're we're
tapping pockets of of isolated support
but that isolated support is not finding
a good way to communicate with the peers
who are like-minded in other parts of
the University and so in a way Patricia
Renfro is here from the library too she
and I and others and their few others in
the room who've been working the faculty
to raise awareness but this is the route
that we need to go at Columbia there
isn't a faculty Senate where we can
introduce this subject and begin to
engage people on these issues at that
level we just don't have it we're an
amalgamation of schools and departments
and that's making the movement in the
direction that you described very
difficult we really don't even have even
Harvard was split into its different
schools but they started with a big
mainstay school of faculty of Arts and
Sciences
and and while we have that kind of
school we don't have the Senate the
organized Senate with faculty Authority
functioning within all of the schools
and so even there there's unevenness
across the institution so that's been
part of the challenge that's been a big
part of the challenge
I realize this is really probably is I
don't think we really have that problem
in astronomy because preprint server had
become the default like
you know repository still the concept
with you
you guys are the poster child physicists
invented the web right so but you're
still using web 1.0 even and even with
archive right re because archive was
preprints the preprint server was the
u.s. post office right until so I mean
that's a huge thing I think the cultural
differences in disciplines are enormous
I mean my career started in astronomy so
I mean I can remember going to places
like Noa oh and seeing yellow papers
posted on the doors right the precursor
to pre prints that we then slapped on to
Paul Keynes marks computer and made
archive out of but that that that
doesn't that does that that culture
doesn't just translate neatly into
biological sciences yeah actually a
little bit more forward chemistry they
would never share their stuff ahead of
time I mean the idea of preprints good
lord sociologists I don't want anybody
seeing my stuff before I milk my dataset
for all it's worth
there are loads of disciplinary
differences that I mean it's really
interesting actually
right clearly all your eggs out there
I'm sorry physics is a totally different
world we do in physics too though I mean
there's this really interesting movement
in high-energy physics are you where the
scope 3 proposal to flip the entire
discipline of high-energy physics to an
open access model this is this proposal
that CERN's got out on the table that
they're asking us collectively to look
for a way to fund the the the flipping
of all the APS journals institute of
physics Springer a couple of other the
major publishers just in high-energy
physics they want us to take the current
investment that we're making to support
subscriptions and essentially reinvested
into a payment that would keep those
journals going but under an open access
model and the request is coming from the
from CERN saying that physicists are
using the preprint server so much that
the journals are actually in danger of
you know going by it going the way of
the dinosaur and there's a concern that
then what will we use in fizz in
high-energy physics for you know quality
benchmarking tenure and promotion then
we need this imprimatur of this final
journal quality so it's physics is in a
completely different position than just
about any other discipline that I can
think of I just want to add to them and
the other odd thing about the physics
situation is that those journals are
still considered very important for
credentialing and promotion and tenure
so they're being published at
considerable expense and taking a big
chunk of library budgets just for that
sort of credentialing and long-term
archiving role in the literature which
is sort of somewhat insane given that
you're all reading in in the archive and
getting all your access in there
you sort of wish there could be a
credentialing from the archive instead
there would be a far more economic way
of doing this
elevated status of being market leader
computer
that's it conspire already like any
gravity so this but so for the really
forward-thinking disciplines lie and I
made this I was invited to address the
Executive Committee of the American
Physical Society and I tried this out on
them right that this is what member
service ought to be that peer review
ought to be disaggregated from the
dissemination and that scholarly
societies ought to be taking care of the
peer review function for the discipline
and let the dissemination take place
through archive or other other formats
and so please take that idea and run
with it I think you're it would be great
and I think physics would clearly be the
first discipline to be willing to
contemplate a model like that but it's
again once you start thinking digitally
you can disaggregate so many things that
were bundled in analog world for analog
reasons
but I would I would say ask two
questions when are you a member of
American Physical Society if any of you
are members of scholarly societies this
is a hugely important role that you can
play to talk to your scholarly societies
as the members as the people they're
supposed to be serving about what your
vision is for how they should be
disseminating your material it shouldn't
just be the conversation shouldn't just
be limited to this is how I want you to
manage my copyright I mean there are
these kinds of issues that that they're
they're supposed to be listening to you
but I think a lot of members of
scholarly societies are not speaking up
and saying this is the direction I want
to go in ApS lobbies extremely hard
against things like the NIH policy even
though it doesn't directly affect them
there are people that are that we run
into probably the most frequently in in
favor of things like that HR 801 and in
opposition of the NIH policy it is sort
of shocking but those are the positions
that scholarly societies your scholarly
societies are taking that are I would
think in direct opposition with what may
be your desire for them to do would be
and they're not hearing for members
otherwise so they're continuing to act
in that way it's a hugely important role
for individual society members to take
hey yeah I want to thank you all for
coming this may be the last one for this
year but there will be another series
next year